je peux vous poser une question bien sûr
ce qui vous a le plus manqué dans ce
refuge je pense que c'est vous
mademoiselle
pardon
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et Jacques
la nuit mais tu es écrasé sur la terre
il avait suffi de 8 mètres pour me
briser les côtes les vertèbres le crâne
quand c'était dans un lit je m'étais dit
à voix presque route
si je m'en sors je traverse la France à
pied
[Musique]
si je réussissais ma traversée
j'obtiendrai réparation
je vais partir du sud-est en direction
de la Manche jusqu'à la mer pire c'est
de la folie est en a conscience oui mais
si je pars pas je pète les plombs tu as
plus de 1000 bornes
[Musique]
les gens qui s'installent ici ils
veulent du Haut Débit avant même de
savoir si une école ou une crèche Les
néo-ruraux
les motifs pour battre la campagne
j'aurais pu en aligner des dizaines
mais la vraie raison de cette fuite à
travers chant
je la tenais serré sous la forme d'un
papier froissé au fond de mon sac